[موسيقى]
بشكل كبير تتصاعد التوترات في البحر
الاسود منذ انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق الحبوب
اواسط يوليو تموز الماضي موسكو حذرت من ان
سفن المتجهه الى الموانئ الاوكرانيه يمكن
اعتبارها اهدافا عسكريه بينما هددت
اوكرانيا باستهداف صادرات الطاقه الروسيه
واعلنت ان الموانئ الروسيه المطله على
البحر الاسود معرضه لخطر الحرب اعتبارا من
الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر ومع ارتفاع
منسوب التوتر في البحر الاسود ترتفع
المخاوف من اتساع رقعه الصراع وما قد
يترتب عليها من تداعيات كارثيه على الامن
الغذائي العالمي في هذه الاثناء تتواصل
المساعي التركيه مع كل الاطراف المعنيه
لاحياء اتفاق تصدير الحبوب وسط انباء عن
لقاء مرتقب نهايه الشهر بين الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين فالى اين تتجه الحرب المستعره فوق
مياه البحر الاسود وهل تنجح انقره في
مساعيها الراميه لاقناعي موسكو بالعوده
الى اتفاق تصدير الحبوب وكيف سيؤثر اي رفض
روسي لتجديد الاتفاق على الامن الغذائي
العالمي اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم منذ انهيار اتفاق الحبوب في
منتصف يوليو تموز الماضي زادت وتيره
الهجمات الروسيه على البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ الاوكرانيه بشكل بات يهدد بشل
قدره كييف على ايصال صادراتها من الحبوب
وتسبب في ازمه امدادات غذائيه بالاسواق
العالميه عن مصير هذا الاتفاق والتداعيات
المحتمله لعدم تجديده على الامن الغذائي
خاصه في بعض الدول التي تعتمد بشكل كبير
على واردات القمح ومنها دول عربيه يسعدنا
ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور فاضل الزعبي خبير الامن
الغذائي بمركز جنيف للدراسات والممثل
السابق لمنظمه الفاو في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط من انقره الدكتور محينا تمام
الباحث في مركز الدراسات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه ومن موسكو الباحث
والمحلل السياسي رونالد بيجاموفا اهلا بهم
جميعا
تتواصل اذا الهجمات المتبادله بين روسيا
واوكرانيا على مرافق البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والسفن التجاريه وتسببت هذه
الهجمات في ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب في
الاسواق العالميه بعد ان اتلفت الاف
الاطنان من الحبوب المعدله للتصدير في هذه
الهجمات وكان حلف شمال الاطلسي قد حذر من
مخاطر جديده لسوء التقدير والتصعيد فضلا
عن عوائق خطيره امام حريه الملاحه بعد
انسحاب موسكو من مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود
البحر الاسود ساحه الحرب الاخرى على تخوم
اوكرانيا حرب الغذاء
تظهر هذه الصور التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ما جرى في عمليه انزال نفذتها
القوات الروسيه على سفينه شحن قالت انها
كانت متجهه الى ميناء اوكراني ولم تستجب
لطلقات تحذيريه من البحريه الروسيه
تقول اوكرانيا وداعمها الغربيون ان البحر
الاسود لم يعد امنا للتجاره البحريه منذ
انسحبت روسيا من صفقه تصدير الحبوب في
يوليو الماضي من اجل ذلك تكثف الوساطه
التركيه مساعيها لبحث بدائل تنقذ العالم
من ازمه غذاء تلوح في الافق بوادر تفاقمها
ماخذ موسكو على الاتفاقيه ان مضمونها تجسد
في شطر منه يتيح تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
لكنه ظل معطلا في الشطر الخاص بالصادرات
الروسيه
قال السفير الروسي لدى انقر ان الاتفاقيه
تضمن بنصها ايضا وصول المنتجات الزراعيه
والاسمده الروسيه الى الاسواق العالميه
وذلك ما لم يتحقق بسبب استمرار العقوبات
الغربيه
ما تريده روسيا ولم يتحقق حتى الان هو ان
يعاد قطاعها المصرفي الى شبكه سويفت
الدوليه ما يسمح لها بتحويل الاموال
واستئناف صادرات منتجاتها والسماح للشركات
الروسيه بالوصول الى اصولها في الخارج
وتلك مطالب تقول موسكو ان الغرب يتنكا في
تنفيذها فجاء ردها باستهداف البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه واعتبار
الممرات التي كانت امنه للشحن في البحر
الاسود ساحه حرب معلنه
بحثا عن خيارات اخرى ذكرت صحيفه وولز
جورنال ان الولايات المتحده تجري مفاوضات
مع اوكرانيا والوسيط التركي لانشاء مسارات
بديله لكن محاولات جرت بالفعل لتصدير
القمح الاوكراني عبر موانئ ابديله
كالموانئ الكرواتيه توصف بالمتعثره
والمكلفه لا مفر والحاله هذه من ازمه غذاء
في السوق العالميه ففي نهايه الشهر الماضي
حذر صندوق النقد الدولي من انسحاب روسيا
من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب قد يرفع اسعارها
بنحو 15%
تعزز ذلك تقديرات الولايات المتحده بتراجع
كبير في مخزونات القمح لسبعه مصدرين
رئيسيين في العالم الى ادنى مستوى منذ سته
عشر عاما بسبب اثار التغيرات المناخيه
الحاده وهذا ما يجعل الدول المستورده
للقمح عرضه لصدمات الاسعار ونقص المعروض
ومع تراجع الانتاج لدى الدول المصدره في
مقابل وفره الانتاج في الاتحاد الروسي
وحاله الحصار في البحر الاسود يطرح السؤال
الان هل ستفلح موسكو في فرض منطقها بان لا
تترك للغرب مخرجا من ازمه الغذاء المحدقه
الا برفع العقوبات عنها
البحر الاسود الذي يتحول في الاونه
الاخيره الى ساحه الصراع يحظى باهميه
استراتيجيه واقتصاديه كبرى لكل من روسيا
واوكرانيا وقد تزايدت اهميته منذ بدايه
الحرب كشريانا اساسيا يتيح للسفن التجاريه
الروسيه والاوكرانيه الوصول الى بلدان
تعتمد في وارداتها من الحبوب على هذين
البلدين
الواقع على الساحل الشمالي الشرقي للبحر
الاسود يعد احد اكبر الموانئ الروسيه من
حيث الحجم وهو نقطه انطلاق رئيسيه لتصدير
الحبوب والاسمده والسلع المختلفه الى جميع
انحاء العالم فقد اعلنت روسيا العام
الماضي تصدير حوالي 15 مليون طن من الحبوب
وتسعه وخمسين مليون طن من النفط عبر هذا
الميناء اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فاميناو
اوديسا هو اكبر ميناء تملكه البلاد على
البحر الاسود اذ كانت تصدر منه قد الحرب
اكثر من خمسين بالمئه من اجمالي صادراتها
وقد تعرض الميناء الذي يعتبر اكبر ميناء
لتصدير الحبوب في العالم لضربات جويه
روسيه منذ انتهاء العمل باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب وفقا للامم المتحده فقد صدرت
اوكرانيا قرابه 33 مليون طن من الحبوب منذ
اغسطس الماضي عبر موانئها على البحر
الاسود وذلك بموجب اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
اهلا وسهلا بك
هذا في البحر الاسود وقصف موانع واعتراض
سفن الى اي مدى يعمق مشكله الحبوب المعقده
اصلا
يعني شكرا على هذه النقطه تحديدا وكان سوق
الغذاء ووضع الامن الغذائي لا يكفي من
هموم اخرى حتى تاتي الغاء مبادره او
اتفاقيه مبادره البحر الاسود ومن ثم الخوض
والوصول الى تدمير المخزون الاستراتيجي
والمخاذي من الموجوده المنشات الموجوده في
الموانع الاوكرانيه او حتى ليس بخف فقط
على البحر الاسود في الموانئ الموجوده على
نهر الدانوب وهذا كله يعمق من الخوف
والقلق في سوق الغذاء ودمر حتى بعض
الصوامع التي تخزن ايضا الحبوب في الموانئ
ذاتها تحديدا في مخازن رينه اللي هي على
البحر الاسود هذه المخازن الكبيره التي
كانت تخزن استعدادا للتصدير تدويرها كان
مؤثرا وسوف يعيق عمليه حتى العوده الى سوق
الغذاء العالمي وهنا هذا المنبع الاساسي
اخلاء خلق القلق في سوق الغذاء يؤثر على
الاسعار وبشكل
يؤذي الدول الفقيره والدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض وهكذا
لنسال ضيفنا من موسكو السيد رونالد بيجامه
اهلا وسهلا بك
هذا التصعيد من وجهه النظر الروسيه ما
الذي يمكن ان يقود اليه واصلا المشكل
موضوع الحبوب مطروح مثل مقال ضيفنا اصلا
هو معقد يعني
مساء الخير هو طبعا هناك تصعيد المتبادل
من الطرفين ولكن روسيا هدفها تنفيذ
المذكره التي هي وقعتها معلومه الامم
المتحده ولكن للاسف الشديد هذه المذكره
صارت مثل مذكره سوى التفاهم لان اكلات
طرفين لديهما استفسار خاص الامم المتحده
تقول انها هي تبذل الجهود لتنفيذ هذه
المذكره روسيا تقول انديها حوالي خمسه
بنوك للمعطون المطالب يعني هو روسي
الخزبانك ربطه
غيار
وخطا المينيا وايضا لوجستيات
لا لم يتم تنفيذ
ومطالب روسيا فلذلك يبدو ان روسيا اتخذت
قرارا حاسما بعدما مددت
[موسيقى]
المذكره البحر الاسود طاوات امارات هذه
المره اتخذت قرارا حاسما
للقضاء على هذه الصفقه ومن اصابه تخيل انه
قريبا سيتم انعاش هذه الصفقه دون تلبيه
المتطلبات الروسيه بحيث تكون
هذه المساله سيتم حلها لصالح الطرفين
ولصالح البشريه كلها اما الان في زول هذا
التصعيد العسكري من قبل الجانبين وضربه
البنيه التغطيه المشكله تبدو صعبه لا شك
ان هذا سيعمق
المشكل ايضا بالنسبه لتركيا الدكتور محي
الدين نتمان هذا التصعيد في البحر الاسود
هل سيجعل مهمه تركيا في العوده لاتفاق
الحبوب اكثر تعقيدا
نعم بالضبط
اعتقد ذلك
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون ان روسيا
قررت في السابق
سبقا كرت انسحابها من اتفاق الحبوب
وبالتالي ليست مرعونه لكن هذه المره
اعطينا القياده السياسيه في روسيا هذه
المره اكثرت جديه
وعزمونا على عدم العوده الى مائده
المفاوضات وهناك ثلاثه ادعاءات للجانب
الروسي احدها ان هناك بعض المشاكل في تدفق
الاموال الناجمه عن هذا عن تصدير الحبوب
والثاني الحظر
المفروض على تصدير الاسمده الروسيه
والدعاء الثالث هو ان الدول الفقيره لم
تستفد بما يكفي من هذه الصفقه وبالتالي
هذه يتساؤلات رئيسيه يطرحها الجانب الروسي
لحد الان
وعندما ننظر الى الارض نجد انه فعل هناك
بعض الصحه
بعض
للاسف نحاول العوده لضيفنا في في
بعض الدول
بعض الدول الدول الغربيه تحاول منذ فتره
بفرض عقوبات على روسيا اولا في حين ان
العقوبات هذه على روسيا تسبب
اسماء عالميه كبيره ازمه فيما يتعلق
بالامن الغذائي وازمات اخرى وبالتالي هذا
يؤدي الى مشاكل انسانيه وبقيه العالم بما
ذلك تركيا يحاولون لهذا السبب ان يحققوا
نوع من حل التوازن التوازن من اجل حل
مشكله الامن الغذائي في العالم
ولكن الامور تزداد سوءا
واعتقد ولهذا تركيا كانت تتوقع ان الرئيس
بوتين سيزور تركيا خلال الشهر اغسطس اب
ولكن لحد الان لم
لم يجري تاكيد ذلك من جانب الروسي هناك
بعض العمل جاري في هذا الصدد
وبالتالي يبدو ان الجانب الروسي عازم
تماما ويتوقع ان يحصل على شيء ما مقابل
ذلك تركيا دكتور زعبي وهي تحاول احياء هذا
الاتفاق وتجديد
تعترض بهذا الموقف
الروسي الذي يقول بانه لا مجال لاعاده
تجديد الا اذا اخذنا في الاعتبار المطالب
الروسيه بمعنى ان رفع العقوبات او السماح
لصادرات روسيا ان تتدفق هل هل ترى في هذا
نوع من الابتزاز كما يصفه البعض
هو نوع من الابتزاز وفي نفس الوقت نوع من
الاستغراب بانك تطلب من جهه شيئا لا تملكه
انت تطلب وتتفق مع تركيا ولا متحده على
رفع العقوبات وادخالك في سويفت والسماح
والسماح وهكذا كله وهذه عقوبات غربيه
وليست عقوبات المتحده ولا تركيا اذا هنا
احنا وقعنا في اشكال كل ما سوف تحصل عليه
هو الوعد
وخليني بس اذكر استاذنا الكريم بانه الكل
بدا يتباكى وكان موضعه موضعه الامن
الغذائي وكان الكل كثير الطرفي النزاع
وطرفي الحرب كل همهم الاساسنه الموضوع
الامن الغذائي الذي الان يستخدم كسلاح
ويستخدم كورقه سياسيه للضغط بهذا الاتجاه
بينما
نتحدث عن القمح الاوكراني 8 مليون طنق
الالعاب هنالك القمح الروسي 35 مليون طنقه
خلال عام فاذا انت مهتم جدا في وضع الامن
الغذائي
35 تشكل اراحه اكثر لسوق الحبوب للفقراء
والجوعاء في العالم
وتاكيدا لهذا المنطق السفير
الروسي في
[موسيقى]
انقرهوف يقول يجب ان لا نبالغ في اهميه
الحبوب الاوكرانيه لانها تمثل 5% من سوق
القمح العالمي بينما نحن نمثل عشرين
بالمئه اذا في هذا الجانب على الاقل روسيا
لديها بعض الوجاهه في موقفها اذا كان
الهدف الامني الغذائي اما اذا كان الموضوع
سياسي فالاستغلال الان بصوته اعلى واللي
يحاول الاستغلال المناظر بشكل اقوى اما
اذا تحدثنا من ناحيه الامن الغذائي هذا
سوق غذاء عالمي ينتج 800 مليون طن في سوق
التجاره هنالك 200 مليون طن ما تشارك فيه
وما شاركت فيه اوكرانيا 80 مليون طن
وهنالك 35 مليون في روسيا وفي نفس الوقت
السنه الانت اعلى يعني ممكن يوصل للاربعين
مليون وهذا رقم مهم جدا في سوق كل كله في
العالم 200 مليون طن المهم على الاسعار
مهم على الوفره مهم على سهوله الوصول
وخلينا نتذكر شغله واحده انه معلش الدول
ذات الدخل المنخفض للعالم والتي تعاني من
انعدام الامن الغذائي الشديد كثيره ولكن
لا تصبح هي
الشماعه سماعه التي يحاول الكل ان يتبهك
عليها وفي نفس الوقت لا يعمل شيئا حتى
الغرب هذه الدول التي تعاني من الديون
طلبت العموم المتحده قبل شهر اعفائها لمده
ثلاث سنوات من ديونها حتى تصبح عند القدره
على اطعام شعبها فالكل يحاول استغلال
الموضوع بهذا الشكل ونعمل
يحصل شيء في هذا الشهر هو هو ربما يحصل
اذا اخذنا مقالته وكاله تاس هنا نسال
ضيفنا
السيد بجموب حسب وكاله تقول من المرجح
التمديد في اتفاقيه الحبوب الامور الفنيه
تم الانتهاء منها الان فقط ننتظر القرار
السياسي هل فعلا المساله قد تكون وشيكه
لا اعتقد ذلك صراحه يعني على روح من
الجانب التركي يسعى لذلك لتروش هذه الفكره
وانعاش هذه المبادره ولكن حتى الان
القيادات الروسيه مصممه في قرارها واعتقد
انه لن يخذس ذلك
قريبا لان الغرب لا يتنازل وايضا موسكو
تدرك جيدا ان اردوغان لا يملك
القوه الكافيه للضغط على الولايات المتحده
وعلى الامم المتحده هناك الراي مفرده بانه
اردوغان ربما سيستطيع ان يلعب دور الوسيط
ويضغط على
الامم المتحده لغوترش ولكن فيها درجه
الاولى على بايدن لان القياده الروسيه
واثقه بين مان يقف وراء اوكرانيا هو
الغربه بقياده
فلذلك هناك
احتماليه قد تكون هناك سيناريوهات اخرى
لحل هذه المشكله ربما سيلعب تركيا
دورا
للمركز
للحبوب الروسيه كما حدث ما الغاز الروسي
وفي نفس الوقت تعتقد انها على الرغم من
التصعيد في البحر ستكون الامكانيه لبعض
السفن التجاريه ان تبحروا وحتى سيتم هناك
نوع من الاتفاق للالتزام ببعض القوايد
الخاصه
بالقانون الدولي وخاصه القانون
الانساني البخري بحيث حتى لو يتم التوتيش
بعض السفن
سيتم هذا وفقا للقانون وهناك ايضا القلق
من مثلا جانب الاوكراني ايضا اع بانه
ستضرب الموان يا روسيا اصابه المانيا
البحر الاسود منها خمسه مواني هي موانية
تجاريه باحثه
ولا نستطيع انها
اهداف عسكريه فلذلك الارجح خلال شهرين او
ثلاثه اشهر خطي لا لن يتبين في نهايه
المطاف نتيجه الهجوم الاوكراني في الجبهه
لا نعرف ماذا سيحدث ولكن هذه هي المفاوضات
ستكون جاريه ولكن قليله الاحتمال ان
ستتوجد
ستعطي بثمار طيبه وفي اقرب الوقت ربما كل
هذه الامور سيتم حلها تدريجيا مع مرور
الزمن زمن وخاصه في اطار
الاتفاقيات الشامله
ستلبي مصالح جميع الاطراف المشاركه في هذا
الصراع الرئيس اردوغان سيد اتمان في انقره
يبدو متفهما لوجهه النظر الروسيه بانه لا
يمكن
التسامح مع الصادرات الاوكرانيه والتغاضي
عن الصادرات الروسيه لابد ان يكون هناك
نوع من التوازن بين الامرين
وهناك مصادر تقول بانه تلقى بعض الضمانات
الشفهيه من الدول الغربيه لنوع من التسامح
في هذه المساله هل تعتقد بانه سينجح في
ذلك
انه هذه المره تركيا والرئيس اردوغان
يواجهان تحديا اكبر
اذ يبدو ان الامور ستكون صعبه جدا اللي
سوى الحظ تركيا والرئيس اردوغان في هذه
المرحله هم الامل الوحيد للعالم وللجانبين
جانبين متحاربين لاجل حل هذه الازمه وكما
قلت سابقا الاولويه بالنسبه للدول الغربيه
خاصه الولايات المتحده مختلفه تماما
وبالتالي عندما ننظر الى الارض نجد ان
صفقه الحب هذه هي مساله انسانيه ان لم تحل
فانها ستؤدي الى ضرر كبير جديد كبير
بالنسبه لدول الفقيره وهي الدول القاره
الافريقيه والشرق الاوسط وفي بعض الدول
الاخرى وكل هذه الدول في الوقت ذاته هم
الشركاء حوار مع روسيا وبالتالي ان روسيا
بشكل غير مباشر ستعاقب
شركائها في افريقيا والشرق الاوسط معظم
الدول العربيه مثلا الدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ودول الجامعه العربيه
ما فتوا يدعون روسيا العوده الى ماده
المفاوضات
اذن فان تركيا من ناحيه
تقع بين شيئين بين توقعين
بين راييين متناحاربين وهو ان ذلك الفائز
تركيا والسيده دغان عليهما ان يقنعاها
الطرفين ولذلك
فانما نحتاجه حقا هو هو
اتفاقيه اكثر شموليه واكثر استدامه
روسيا عفوا تركيا ستواصل الدفع من اجل
اتفاقيه مستدامه ولكن هذه المره المهمه
ستكون صعبه جدا بالنسبه للتركيا والرئيس
البرتغال وبالتالي سيكون علينا ان ننتظر
زياره الرئيس بوتين واعتقد
ان معظم النقاط الغير الواضحه لحد الان
سوف
سوف تنظر ويدرس وتدرس بعد زياره الرئيس
بوتين لتركيا اذا علينا ان ننتظر حتى
نهايه شهر اغسطس اب لنرى نهايه هذه
العمليه وخارطه الطريق التي سيرسمها
الطرفان هذه الزياره المرتقبه الدكتور
زعبي لبوتن لتركيا هل يمكن ان تحرك الامور
لانه يفترض ان لا تتم الا اذا كان مهد لها
بطريقه جيده لا اعتقد انه سياتي ويعود دون
ان تستطيع تركي ان ان تظفر بشيء يعني انا
عاجبني قراءتك بهذه الطريقه لانه اتفق معك
الى حد كبير
وعندي بعض من التوقعات والاسباب اولا
روسيا بهذه الاتفاقيه عندما الغتها
ما راح تتركها دائما مكشوفه وعاريه هذه
خلينا نسميها المقاربات تخدم فكره بانه
العوده الى الاتفاق بده يكون بس بنوع من
الاختلاف شويه بنوع من الكرامه السياسيه
بان يتم هذه المره مثلا هذه الوعود معكم
ثلاثه اشهر نحن نعطي الانذار ثلاثه اشهر
ان لم يتم العوده عن هذا الاتفاق ومن هذه
الامور السياسيه التي تفهمها اكثر مني
هناك نقطه
اشار اليها السفير الروسي في انقره وتبدو
غريبه الحقيقه دكتور زعبي يقول
ممر الحبوب الذي يصرخ العالم كله
بشانه في النهايه الذين استفادوا منه هي
الشركات الامريكيه والاوروبيه وان ثلاث
بالمائه فقط حسب ما قال من الصادرات
الحبوب ذهبت الى الدول الناميه اذا كانت
الصوره بهذا بشكل يعني يبدو
الصراخ حول صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه يصبح
محل تساؤل هاي نقطه والنقطه الاخرى قد لا
اتفق كثيرا مع ما ذهب اليه السفير الروسي
لان في روسيا في اسطنبول لانه بالاساس انت
تريد حبوب في هذا السوق سواء راحت للصين
ولا لامريكا او امريكا ما بتستورد او
لاوروبا او للدول الفقيره هي حبوب دخله
السوق العالمي وبالتالي ادت الى استقرار
السعر انت اخذت هذا الجزء اللي جاي من
اوكرانيا انا هاخذ الجزء الاخر الموجود في
السوق فبالتالي هي قضيه استقرار السوق
وحكاها الامين العام المتحده قبل شهر في
قمه نظم الغذاء العالميه في روما وذكر
بانه الوفره ليست مشكله وقال من العيب انه
في في عالم هنالك وفره في الغذاء ولكن
المشكله في الوصول اليه المشكله في قدره
الدول ذات الديون
في شراء هذا الغذاء والمشكله في الفرد ان
يستطيع الوصول اليه اذا المشكله هي سعر
وليست
وفره على كل دكتور بمجرد اعلان روسيا
رسميا انسحابها من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود بدات اسعار الحبوب في
الارتفاع ويعتقد ان الانسحاب ستكون له
تداعيات على سوق الغذاء الدوليه قبل بدء
الحرب كانت اوكرانيا تصدر نحو 60 مليون طن
من الحبوب ثم انخفضت النسبه في ظل الاتفاق
الى نحو 33 مليون طن تقريبا منها تسعه
ملايين طن من القمح وفق احصائيات الامم
المتحده وقال صندوق النقد الدولي ان
انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود قد يرفع
اسعار الحبوب الى نحو 15% وكان برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه تابعه للامم المتحده
اشترى 750 الف طن من القمح الاوكراني
وسلمها الى دول من بينها افغانستان
واثيوبيا والصومال والسودان وجيبوتي وتقول
الامم المتحده ان هذا الاتفاق اسهم في خفض
اسعار الحبوب في العالم بنسبه 20% بعد ان
بلغت مستويات قياسيه مباشره بعد اندلاع
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
دكتور زعبي هناك مفارقه عند الحديث عن
ازمه غذاء عالميه لان عندما نطالع
التقارير يتحدثون عن وفره في الانتاج الان
في السوق العالميه
ومع ذلك ما زال القلق قائما ونتحدث عن
امكانيه ارتفاع الاسعار بمجرد ان البحر
الاسود لا يصدر كالعاده كيف نفهم هذا هو
هذا ما يفسر الوضع بان الوفر ليست مشكله
والمشكله الان تكمن في الاستغلال التجاري
لهذا الموضوع والاستغلال السياسي هذه
بورصه اي حاله عدم يقين اي خبر مثلنا مثل
اي بورصه عالميه يعني بالتحديدا بورصه
شيكاغو اللي هي الكبرى زيها زي اي بورصه
في العالم مجرد اي خبر عن عدم توفر ماده
او احتمال قلاقل في دوله مصدره لماده تبدا
الاسعار بالارتفاع وهنا تكمن الخطوره
بالنسبه لدولنا ودول العالم
لمستورده للقمح وفي الوقت حتى الاستغلال
السياسي بدون قصد وقعت في الامم المتحده
بدات تستغل الموضوع بشكل سياسي يعني الامم
المتحده لما يجي برنامج الغذاء العالم
يقول لك انا اشتريت من اوكرانيا وطعميت
هاي الدول طب انت عندك كل دور العالم
تشتري منها يعني عندك رومانيا اللي هي جنب
اوكرانيا وبلغاريا اللي جنب اوكرانيا انت
تشتري منها انت مش كل مشترياتك وخاصه انت
كجهه اغاثيه توزع هذه المعركه مش كل
المشترياتك هي راح تكون من اوكرانيا الان
في هذه المرحله تقريبا هي التي يخزن فيها
تخزن فيها كل الحبوب الاوكرانيه الان وفي
عنا دول عربيه كامل انتاجها كامل
استيرادها من روماني وليست من اوكرانيا
لذلك ما تاثرت في في كل المواد الاسعار
الحرب بينما تاثرت في الاسعار لانه
الارتفاع الاسعار هو ارتفاع عالمي وحتى
الصادرات الاوكرانيه من المفارقه ان اكثر
المستفيدين منها الصين واسبانيا
وتركيا 12% من من الثمانيه مليون
طن قمح كان راحت لتركي ايضا هناك وجهه نظر
اخرى سيد بجموه في موسكو تقول بان
هذا السعي الروسي لعرقله الصادرات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه انما يعود الى رغبه روسيا في
الاستئثار بالسوق العالميه لان الانتاج
وفير الان في روسيا بشكل كبير وتريد ان
تضايق الصادرات الاوكرانيه حتى تجعل
العالم مضطر للجوء الى الحبوب الروسيه
بشكل خاص هل هذا صحيح وهذا ما ذهبت اليه
مثلا
دعني دعني يعني ندرس الموضوع خطوه خطوه
اولا المقصود الاوكرانيه هذا الامر سيكون
اقل من المغصون من المغصون السابق لي انا
معظم الصوامي الاوكرانيه هي الواقيه في
الجزء المركزي والغربي للبلاد اما
الحبوب كلها زراعات وهي المناطق الجنوبيه
والشرقيه التي الان تحت السيطره روسيا كما
تعرفون
فلذلك بطبيعه الحال الحبوب الاوكرانيه
ستكون يعني اقل من ذلك
وايضا الروس لديهم توقعات هذا الامر
الزراعي ان يصدروا حوالي 55 مليون طن من
الحبوب الى الخارج لان يتوقون المقصود
وهذا دون الاخذين الاعتبار طبعا الحبوب
اربع مناطق
الاوروبيه
246 الف طن منها تم افراج فقط
حاجه صغيره يشرين الف طن لدوله مالاوي
وايضا كانت هناك شحنه اخرى معظم الا
الاسمده الروسيه الان في اوروبا واذا هناك
موضوع العداله شروب يعرفون لا يوجد هناك
الانصاف الغرب مصمم بانه يريد ان
يعني روسيا عن طريق اساليب الاقتصاديه وهو
مبسوط جدا
بعدم تنفيذ المذكره
ولا يتنازل ابدا الغرب امام روسيا على
الاقل في هذه الاشهر القريبه المقبله اما
الروس يقولون انها
المبادره مبادره البحر الاسود يعني الحبوب
الاوكرانيه هي ليست
السحري لان هناك عوامل عديده التي توصل
على على حاله السوق على الحبوب
يعني كل شيء الذي سيدخل في سوق لها شيء
يتم او فقدانه فلذلك الروس طبعا
يستخدمون هذه الورقه
وسيكسبون مزيد من الدعم من الدول الفقيره
التي افقر الدول خاصه الدول الافقر وصلت
اليها بالفعل تضافها بالميه لان الناس
دائما هناك
اللخبطه بين مفهوم الدول الناميه والدول
الفقيره الدول الفقيره وافقر الدول هي
طاوات البنيه ولكن ليست الدول الفقيره هي
الدول الناميه الصين تعتبر دواء الدوله
الناميه ولكن هي لديها حصه الاسد من هذه
الحبوب الاوكرانيه وصلت اليها وطبعا الى
اسبانيا والى غيرها من الدول هي روسيا
ايضا في القمه يعني روسيا في القمه
الاخيره الروسيه الافريقيه ونتحدث عنه
الرئيس بوتين من امكانيه ارسال حبوب الى
الى هذه الدول فهمت على انها خطوه دعايه
سياسيه اكثر منها جدوى حقيقيه ولكن على
الاقل هذا هذا مفاهيمه البعض في الاثناء
نسال ضيفنا السيد عثمان
تركيا لا تبدو مطمئنه تماما
لامكانيه
تجديد اتفاق الحبوب لان بدليل على الاقل
اذا ما اخذنا بما قالته
بانه في الوقت الحالي هناك مفاوضات تجري
بين تركيا واوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
وبعض دول شرق اوروبا للبحث عن امكانيه
ايجاد بدائل فيما اذا تعذر تجديد الاتفاق
هل يمكن التعويل على ذلك
بكل وضوح انا ارى ان ذلك مستحيل لان اي
طريق بديل سيكون غاليا ثمنه ومكلف وسيكون
مستحيل تقريبا
تقديم وتوفير الحبوب لبعض مناطق العالم
مثل الدول القاره الافريقيه والصين وكما
تعلمون فان بعض الخبراء يقولون بان
الطريقه الجديده واحد البدائل
ولكن بالنسبه لي
هل
الطريقه الجديده او اي بدل لاخره امر غير
جيد وغير صحي
وارى ان الطريق الوحيده
للابقاء والمحافظه على
تصدير الحبوب الى اسواق العالميه هي عن
طريق استخدام طريق البحر الاسود عن طريق
تركيا وبالتالي
فان تركيا تحاول منذ فتره ان تضع ضغوط على
الطرفين لاقناعهما
وليبقى طريق البحر الاسود مفتوحا للطرفين
والا فسيكون وضع يخسر فيه الطرفان الطرف
اللي وكذلك الطرف الروسي
وان الاطراف المتحاربه طبعا
تريد الاستفاده او استغلال هذا الوضع هذه
الصفقه الحبوب استغلالها
لمصلحتهما
وذلك
لسوء تطبيق واستخدام الاتفاق بينما
بالنسبه لتركيا الوضع مختلف تماما طبعا
تركيا من هذا الصفقه
فتركيا
تستخدم منذ فتره هذه الحبوب
بتحويلها الى معكرونه وما الى ذلك من
المنتجات الغذائيه ثم تصدرها الى الدول
الافريقيه
والجانب غير الغربي من العالم ومن جانب
اخر تركيا لا تريد ان يحصل التصعيد في
منطقه البحر الاسود لذلك فانها ستعبئ كل
مواردها
وتعبئ كل القدراتها لحل المشكله
ولمنعه التصعيد في منطقه البحر الاسود اذا
تعذر دكتور زعبل الوصول الى تجديد الاتفاق
ما هي اكثر الدول
التي ستتضرر اكثر من غيرها او المناطق على
الاقل
اساسي
نفس الدول التي تعاني اساسا من وضع انعدام
الامن الغذائي والتزوير والسوء والتغذيه
معظمها في دول غرب اسيا ودول وسط افريقيا
وقليلا في الكاريبي لكن بشكل اساسي هذه
الدول هذه الدول لان وضعها سيء ووضح
المادي ايضا
والاقتصادي خليني اسميه ايضا لا يؤهلها
لمجارات هذه الصدمه في الاسعار فهي راح
تكون اكثر الدول المتاثره في الموضوع يعني
لما تيجي تنظر الى دوله زي الصومال نصف من
يعانون من اعدام الامن الغذائي في العالم
موجودين فيها هذا رقم كبير جدا لما تيجي
تنظر الى انه 40% من يعانوا من الوضع
الطارئ في الامن الغذائي موجودين في اربع
دول اليمن وجنوب السودان وبوركينا فاسو
والكونغو فبالتالي هذه الدول راح يكون
وضعها
بس اذا سمحت لي انا في عندي نقطه بحب
اضيفها تفضلي يعني الان احنا اثرنا كل هذه
الجلبه على القمح
احنا الان يحصل لدينا على لست نحن طبعا
اقصد المجتمع الدولي لدينا نفس الوضع في
الارز وما يحصل به بعد قرار الهند عدم عدم
السماح بتصدير العرج وبعد قرار تايلاند
تحويل المزارعين من الرز الذي يستهلك
المياه الكثيره الا مواد اخرى اذا اذا
هنالك ايضا خطر على الامن الغذائي اذا كان
القصد من كل هذا التباكي هو الامن الغذائي
اذا لم يكن الاهداف الاخرى هذا من ناحيه
من ناحيه اخرى
لنفترض انا اريد كروسيا مثلا
ان احل موضوع الامن الغذائي واسحب هذه
الورقه من يد الغرب كل ما صدرته اوكرانيا
بموجب هذه الاتفاقيه تحديدا من القمح 8
مليون طن وانا كروسيا وعدت الدول
الافريقيه ضمن القمه اللي تمت بانه اوصل
لهم القمح رحب ما رح يكون مشكله ثمانيه
مليون طن من حدود 40 مليون طلقه قمح
موجوده لدى روسيا ان تقوم بشحنها وذكرت
انه حتى الشحن سوف نقوم نحن بشحنه ان تقوم
خلال عام بشحنها لهذه الدول وبالتالي
اعاده الاستقرار الى سوق الغذاء العالمي
لانه ما راح يكون في طلب فلاحظ يعني كل
المقاربات اللي بحاول معظم الاطراف
استخدامها هي لاهداف اخرى غير ما يغنون به
وهو انعدام الامن الغذائي في العالم ايضا
عند الحديث عن الازمه الحاليه يقسمون
الاسباب الى ثلاث اسباب هناك حاله جفاف
ظاهره في العالم اكيد هناك
تعطل الصادرات الروسيه ليست كالعاده بسبب
الحرب وهناك صادرات الاوكرانيه لماذا
التركيز على الصادرات الاوكرانيه تحديدا
يبدو ان التوظيف السياسي اكثر من الوقائع
العلميه في هذا الشان سيدي هو ذلك لماذا
الثمانيه مليون
الاخرى الموجود على الطرف الاخر الى راح
العالم للاسترسام سياسي
عن 33 مليون حبوب حبوب يتحدث عن قمح القمح
قمح
بشكل عام بشكل حبوب
لتاثيرها اقل تاثير المباشر هو في في رغيف
الخبز ولكن هل هل عندما نتحدث عن خطر يهدد
الامن الغذائي الا يمكن ايضا ان نركز على
ضروره
رفع العقوبات عن عن روسيا على الاقل في
هذا الجانب لان اذا كان الهم الرئيسي هو
الامن الغذائي العالمي القضيه ليست حبوب
اوكرانيا فقط حبوب روسيا ايضا اذا ما
العمل في هذا في هذا الجانب هو هذا هذا
وان ابين الجميع بانه بغض النظر من هو
المستفيد والهدف السياسي وراء من وضع 14
الف عقوبه او وراء من يحاول استغلال الوضع
من اجل رفع العقوبات انا كمواطن في دوله
تعاني من انعدام الامن الغذائي انا كابن
شمال افريقيا والشرق الادنى اللي يستورد
القمح انا احاول ان استفيد بوصول الغذاء
رخيصا لي فبالتالي ابعدوه عن سياساتكم
وجعلوا المتاح لي من القمح الاوكراني
والقمح الروسي حتى استطيع ان نعم في نهايه
البرنامج سنقوم بجولتنا المعتاده بين
ضيوفنا بشكل سريع لو سمحتم
عن ما هو السيناريو الذي تتوقعونه لمستقبل
هذه الازمه المتعلقه بالحبوب والامن
الغذائي العالمي نبدا بضيفنا من موسكو سيد
بيجام
بشكل سريع
الجيني التواصل الى اتفاق قريبا ربما يخص
شهرين ولكن اعتقد ان انا ارجه
السيناريوهات هو انشاء مركز لحبوب روسيه
لتوزيع الحبوب في روسيا مع معالجتها في
الصناعه التركيه في تركيا وتركيا تقوم بعد
ذلك
بصادرات هذه الحبوب ونوس الشيء سياخذوا
الحبوب الاوكرانيه اعتقد ان قريبا ايضا
ستتمكن اوكرانيا ارسال هذه السفن مع
الحبوب ولكن هذا مطلوب
دكتوره تمام
اعتقد
وكما قال ضيفكم في الاستوديو
واكد علينا ان نميز بين السياسه والازمه
الانسانيه فهناك ازمتان متوازيتان حاليا
احدهما هي هناك حرب جاريه وازمه سياسيه
جاريه ومن جانب اخر هناك ازمه انسانيه في
العالم اذا لابد ان نميز بين هذين البعدين
بين هذين الازمتين اعتقد ليس بامكان اي
دوله واحده بما ذلك روسيا
والغرب يمكن لا يمكن لا يبالون بما يحصل
في العالم وازمه الغذاء في العالم لابد
للجانبين ان يتفقا على التوصل الى حل ايا
كان الحل اللي هو
للتخفيفه ازمه الغذاء في العالم لان ذلك
سيظهر ويؤذي الدول الفقيره المحتاجه اكثر
وزعلين لابد من حلها بطريقه اخرى دكتور
زعبي بشكل سريع انا اتوقع السيناري الاقرب
الان يعود الاتفاق بشكل اخر يعني هالمره
تعطي روسيا انذار معكم شهرين ثلاثه اشهر
حتى تنفذوا ربط وبالتالي هي التي تعطي
الانذار للجهه الاخرى هذا متوقع لانه هذا
في تحقيق مكاذب اقتصاديه وسياسيه من ناحيه
اخرى الكل يبحث عن بدي اجيب مثل عمي الكل
بيجيب النار على قرصه الكل يبحث عن ان
يستفيد فبالتالي تركيا ان تكون مركزا او
هب او مركز لتوزيع القمح الروسي
والاوكراني سويته هذا كمان امر بناسبه
شكرا جزيلا لك
ونختم بتغريده لفراس برزان وهو باحث في
شؤون دول اوروسيا جاء فيها تعهدت روسيا
بتعويض النقص في الامدادات ليست مغريه لكل
من الصين وتركيا اكبر مستوردي القمح
الاوكراني لارتفاع الاسعار واجبارهم على
زياده الاعتماد على موسكو من جهه اخرى
تهديد وحركه الملاحه المدنيه امر لا تنظر
اليه الصين بايجابيه لاسباب عده وهذا يشكل
ضغطا على خياره موسكو
دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]